حوالي ستة أشهر كان لدينا مهندس واحد
خلفنا في تصميم الطاولة بأكملها ومع
المشروع مع كل الرياضيات التي
ورائها لحساب الوزن وجميع
السيناريوهات المحتملة الأخرى التي كانت لدينا
ولدينا أيضًا خبرة كبيرة في
القفز بالمظلات في الفريق لذلك  لقد كان
مزيجًا من صناعة الفيديو الهندسي أيضًا ،
كما أن Skydive
Skydive تدور حول السلامة التي تعرفها ، لذلك
علينا التفكير في كل
ما نقوم به قبل أن نخاطر
ونرى ما يمكن أن يحدث لذلك علينا
أن نأتي أو نأتي  مع حل
قبل أن يحدث
غريب
على الطاولة ، لذلك
كان هذا يخيفني لأننا لم
نفعل ذلك من قبل كنت
خائفًا لأننا لم نكن نعرف ما
إذا كانت الطاولة ستكون غير مستقرة أم
ستهزها ولذا كان هذا يخيفني
بسبب  بالنسبة لي ، كانت أسوأ نقطة
نستمع إليها عادةً للناس ، فأنتم مجنونون ،
فأنت تفعل شيئًا رائعًا لن أفعله أبدًا لأننا
فعلنا كل ما خططنا له وكان الأمر
مختلفًا بالنسبة لنا كما كنا
نتحدث عن هذا
جنون بعض الشيء ولكن  سنفعل ذلك ، كنا
في مكان ما في عطلة نهاية الأسبوع الماضية
و
2010 ،
كنا شباب البالون الذي
رأيته في وجبة الإفطار ، نعم ، لكننا
سنعيش مشهورًا ، نعم
[الموسيقى]
هي حقًا
والطريقة التي يصنعون بها الفيلم
وتحرير الفيديو ، نعم ،
تحرير الفيديو ، هناك شيئان يجتمعان معًا
ويجعلانه جميلًا حقًا ، لقد كان
إفطارًا رائعًا حقًا ، نعم ،
كان Domingo الخاص مثل الاستمتاع والمشاركة
مثل لحظة فريدة مع الأصدقاء ، ولكن
أيضًا عرض Skydive لجميع الأشخاص
رياضة جميلة وشيء
يمكنك القيام به مثل الأشياء المدهشة ، لذلك نحن
نشارك لحظات مختلفة ومميزة
مع الأصدقاء ،
إنها مزيج رائع من الأصدقاء
يقفزون بالمظلات والمشاريع المجنونة والصفقات المذهلة ،
شكرًا لك